notre dame head coach brian kelly
joining us on the program how optimistic
are you coach that we're going to start
on time when you face
navy i'm optimistic that we're going to
start
you know then students get on campus and
our guys move off campus essentially
dan we leave the bubble and start the
season
so unlike maybe some of the professional
uh teams like the nhl or you know
the nba they move into a bubble and
start their season
college football leaves the bubble and
starts the season so
we'll get to the starting line we'll see
what happens after that but what is your
message
and what will your message be to your
athletes
once school starts and uh you know
campus activities going off campus
socializing what's your priority
if you want to play college football
this fall uh
you'll have to do the things that you've
done over the last uh
four weeks and the numbers speak for
themselves right we've already
you know said that you know you can do
this but you've done it in a
confined environment but they have had
to
do the things necessary right they've
stayed out of the bars they've stayed
away from parties uh
social distancing wearing masks washing
hands all the things that we already
know right we've heard that
day in and day out they'll have to
continue that discipline
and there's going to have to be peer
accountability guys are going to have to
say to other guys
you can't do that because i want to play
this fall and if you do that and you get
me sick
i'm not going to be happy so a big dose
of pure accountability
good dose of guys wanting to play the
season
is really going to be about what happens
when the season starts
have you started practicing no we have
not
we're in strength training and
conditioning
and really it's about four weeks in most
football programs would normally get
about eight weeks stand
prior to their first padded practice so
you know we still got some work to do
relative to uh
the time off you know remember now that
no spring practice
no real designated off-season
these guys were deconditioned a little
bit so we're getting back there but we
still need a little bit more time to
continue to condition our athletes
whose protocols are in place notre dames
or the ncis
notre dames um so this has really been
driven by
each institution uh certainly there's an
eye towards the state's
cdc guidelines and and certainly the
ncaa has
some uh one in particular would be the
72-hour
testing mandate where all teams must be
tested 72 hours prior to competition
but by and large this has been dan about
the institutions putting together their
own
procedures and protocols as it relates
to how to keep their football team safe
and healthy what about non-conference
games being cancelled by
you know we've seen this with the pac-12
the big ten uh
how's that affecting notre dame
well certainly as an independent you
know we we lose some of those
natural rivalries that we've played for
years uh
certainly the usc game uh certainly
stanford
uh we will not play wisconsin but we
have a collateral agreement with the acc
and so we will lean heavily on that jack
swarbrick has
certainly been involved in that in terms
of setting up a schedule we feel very
confident then at the end of the day
we're going to have a very competitive
schedule using acc
uh as a really good partner in this
whole scheduling
for us moving forward now there are
conferences that haven't come out with
not wanting to give up those non-league
games and so
those stay on the table for us as well
so we'll see how that plays out over the
next couple of weeks yeah could you see
where the sec just says we're playing
football whether the pac-12 or
big 12 or big ten you know you know we
talked to uh commissioner sankey that
i don't know if they ruled it out but
could you see where a conference just
says we're taking care of our own here
yeah certainly i could see that uh you
know there's some natural rivalries
right that the
the acc and the sec has right um
you know the south carolina clemson game
you know uh
kentucky louisville uh so you know
florida against florida state you know
we have arkansas
on our schedule uh this year so you know
that's conceivable that those games
uh may want to stay uh on the schedule
so
as i said i think you know the sec is
evaluating
you know the landscape in our country
and where we are and
and i think the acc may be doing that as
well so i think you'll see some things
that that will start to clear up over
the next week
was there a chance you were going to
play alabama
no i don't believe we've got them
scheduled down the road here in a couple
of years so i i think that that was
going to be suffice for us
and certainly those are the kind of
games we want to play we've got ohio
state coming on our schedule wisconsin
alabama in a couple of years so um i
don't believe that that was going to
happen
you know when you're not you know when
you're an independent and uh
you know you you have an open schedule
everybody's going to look towards notre
dame as being the first one that you
fill it with
we're talking to brian kelly the notre
dame head coach who i believe
did you start your coaching career
coaching women's softball
i did yeah it was uh it was a great uh
experiment for me more than an
experiment i think it really laid the
foundation for me in terms of
wanting to be around people that just
love to play
and and the ladies that i coached loved
to play the game there was no
moving on to the professional ranks it
was playing the game because they
loved to play and and i think that
that's what really kind of energized me
in my coaching profession is that uh
i wanted to be around people that just
enjoyed to play and
had that genuine um fire for the game
itself
and you had stops along the way
cincinnati central michigan
uh grand valley state where you won a
couple of national titles
you get to notre dame and i think we
discussed this before
like is does the competitor say now i
want to see what i would do
in the nfl like do you do you harbor
those
thoughts that competitiveness that you
say okay let me see if i could do it in
the nfl
you know i think i did at times i don't
anymore
because i think i've got a better sense
and understanding of what the nfl model
looks like
and and i'd much prefer to have and this
isn't to be said in a manner that i want
control
uh but i do like the fact that that i
can
um have say over my roster uh that i do
have
say over you know who i recruit on a
day-to-day basis and
and and in some senses you probably
wouldn't have it and certainly i
wouldn't as a first-time
nfl head coach have that kind of say and
control
over the fate of where my program would
go or in that sense franchised
so i really like that and having 30
years in college football invested in
having those kind of decisions
it's really difficult to move in another
direction uh
we've talked about the the changing of
the guard the new guard of
quarterbacks coming in and i'm curious
you being an offensive minded guy
the quarterback you're bringing in is it
kind of reflective of what the nfl
is looking for for success there with
lamar jackson
kyler murray uh that dual threat
you know it's interesting that we have
these conversations because
for the last three to five years
everyone had been saying
you know we'll never go to the college
type quarterback in the nfl
he'll never make it he'll never get
through it he'll never get through the
season
and and now it's it's certainly um
it's the best athlete right you know if
you're in high school
who touches the football every time it's
not the corner
you know it's the best athlete is the
quarterback and you know whether it's
cam newton
or whether it's jackson mahomes just got
paid i think he's a pretty good athlete
it's going to be about a guy that can
extend and keep
plays alive outside the realm of
what that guy drew up on the board we're
only as smart as the guy that can keep
the play alive and that's the
quarterback that's a dual athlete
yeah did you recruit any of these guys
were you in on any of these players
at notre dame um you know i think in
some instances
if you look across the board there's a
number of guys that we had conversations
with
uh that are in the nfl today um but
but quarterbacking is is such um an
exact science at that age
you know what i mean everybody has you
know it's the beauty is in the eye of
the beholder and so we have
conversations with a number of guys
across the board
i remember when aaron rodgers was coming
out of junior college and i was in
central michigan
you know we made a call into him and and
you know he wasn't going to leave the
west coast you know and so
you know those kinds of conversation
happened throughout recruiting
whether you actually had any kind of
chance of getting those quarterbacks is
is hard to say but uh had probably
conversations with
10 or 15 quarterbacks in the nfl tom
izzo the michigan state
head coach said it still haunts him that
he missed out on chris webber
is there a player that still haunts you
that you missed out on
oh my you know after doing it for 30
years
uh probably i don't know if you know the
story but i was at central michigan and
uh
you know we we recruited jj watt and we
signed jj watt at central michigan
and then i left to take the job at
cincinnati and and j.j watt left
to go to wisconsin i would have in
retrospect i would have
i i would have packed him up in my
suitcase know guys like that are
once in a lifetime having a chance to to
coach a guy like that
um so those are the ones that come back
to you sometimes yeah but coach you had
him as a tight end though didn't you
yeah we did but you know he was going to
move but i had jason kelsey as a
quarterback
so how smart am i you know you know guys
guys uh you recruit them and you know
you start them in a position and they
eventually move one day
yeah travis kelsey was unbelievable
athlete he is an unbelievable athlete
yeah good yeah we had him as our goal
line quarterback as a true freshman
and uh we knew that he wasn't going to
last very long at the quarterback
position but he was such a
such a great athlete we could have
played him anywhere coach good to talk
to you hopefully we're we're this
optimistic as we get ready to start the
season do you know
if you're starting on september 5th or
6th against uh navy
we really don't know now i mean once
we've uh
obviously you know had the non-league
games uh taken away from us and
in a large degree uh our calendar will
be
probably decided a lot by what the acc
schedule looks like so
sometime next week we'll have a better
understanding of when we start yeah can
you call me and just let me know so i
can plan you know that's a game i like
to watch
naval cat no doubt against notre dame
yeah no no thanks dan appreciate it
thank you coach that's uh coach brian
kelly